hello, how are you, good health, see you and
jaramillo with your brief information for
today, monday, april 5, starting tomorrow,
more students from the clark county school district will
return to classrooms, that
's right, grades 4, 5, 7, 8, 10 and 11 will have
face-to-face classes this  It is the last
group to take a hybrid
learning model since they will be in their classrooms for
two days and at home for the rest of the
week starting Tuesday.
Primary students will begin
full-time face-to-face classes.
The capacity inside the classrooms will be
of  75% while
schools prepare to
accommodate more students good
news for Nevadans starting
today if you are over 16 you will already be able to
receive the coronavirus vaccine
for more registration information
visit our page news now dotcom
diagonal in Spanish yes  you have not yet been
vaccinated and you think you have the virus it is
important that you get a
screening test the audition stadium will be
offered  Doing tests over the counter this
week
on Wednesday from 8 in the
morning until one in the afternoon you can
make an appointment through the
health district page and now we turn to
the weather forecast another hot day is expected
maximum of  today it will be close
to 90 degrees as well as winds are expected
until night the temperatures
will be above normal all
week have a nice day I am from
Jaramillo and this was your brief
news now in Spanish
[Music]